the Northern California coast is one of
the most picturesque places in the
United States so it's no wonder that
this is where a billionaire Tom Steyer
spends his free time
just a few miles inland from the Pacific
is the 18 hundred acre ranch
Steiners wife Catherine Taylor bought in
2002 only an hour outside of San
Francisco it's a world away running this
huge ranch how is it different then what
do you billion dollar hedge funds all
day how it's the same how it's
incredibly different it's the same in
the sense that you think if this looks
like an asset but it's actually
dramatically changed by the people who
run and that's exactly like every
organization I've been in which is
having great people particularly the top
is unbelievably significant and powerful
and that's where the comparison ends
Tomcat Ranch has a staff of 15 including
scientists who are studying ecologically
friendly ways to raise cattle you
basically move the animals from place to
place and that's actually how they call
them undulant how you know the big herds
of animals have moved across the plains
of the earth I think at this point what
we would think of as real success is if
it turns out scientifically that we're
right that the way that we're grazing
the different animals causes the land to
soak up twice as much carbon as normal
steyr has always buffed against
conventional wisdom he and his wife
chose to settle here on the west coast
near their alma mater Stanford
University and thousands of miles from
Wall Street I intentionally chose not to
live in New York City
which is the center of investment the
United States I never felt as if I was
really part of that community even
though I had lots of friends in it is
that why you left Wall Street I just
didn't think the I didn't think didn't
think it'd be a great place and I don't
think my wife thought would be a great
place to have little kids
and you know if you like the
out-of-doors I mean we're sitting in
Pescadero California in the out-of-doors
be hard to recreate steyr tries to get
out to his ranch a few times a week in
addition to raising grass-fed cattle the
ranch plays host to local schoolchildren
who come to visit Dorothy the 300-pound
Pig